[Music]  there's this trick that we all do to get  through our day we take a box and into  that box we place all the horrors of the  world we close the box we pretend it  doesn't exist only some of us we've lost  our ability to pretend we're looking for  a special operator like you for a while  who are you we do the dirty work  others can't here's the fun part  an airline you're dead it's all erased  by more criminal records no more getting  arrested just for being naked or just  usual stuff you know being naked getting  drunk casual stuff so we're all gonna  die we blend in to disappear watch me  I hope so  this mine honestly I didn't think we'd  make it this far  [Music]  what's wrong Hey  we're all gonna die  may as well do it while we're alive  sounds fun right  [Applause]  you  [Music]